today on the matt wall show a new york
times writer says he's given up
on reaching out to trump voters after
all of his outreach efforts have failed
but we can learn something important
about the leftist mentality
from the way he went about this supposed
outreach so we'll talk about that today
also five headlines including a press
conference held by trump's lawyers
laying out their voter fraud claims uh
some of them quite extraordinary tucker
carlson says that
one of his one of trump's lawyers sydney
powell has refused to provide
any of the evidence she claims to have
so we'll try to make sense of all that
today
and our daily cancellation new york
magazine produces
honestly one of the most racist videos
you will ever see in your life probably
the most racist video you'll ever see on
youtube
and it is allowed on youtube we're gonna
play that today and of course everyone
involved in that will be cancelled
first i want to tell you about one of
our new sponsors on the show we're very
excited about relief band
you know uh if you have the experience
of of
of car sickness in particular motion
sickness which is something that i deal
with
if i'm driving then i'm okay but um you
know taking uber i do i uber a lot
especially now that i live in
in the city and so i get i get bad
motion sickness in the car
um and to the point where you know i've
had a few times where i've
it's like a 30 minute ride and i'm i'm
almost at the the point of having to ask
them to pull over so i can puke and that
would be very embarrassing
and so i'm always looking for solutions
and um i found one here it's called
relief band
so i'm very excited about our new powder
relief band is the number one
fda cleared anti-nausea wristband that
has been clinically proven to relieve
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness morning sickness
chemotherapy anxiety hangovers migraines
and so much more
the product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
fast-acting
and provides all natural relief with
zero side effects
and it really does worth work uh and the
fact that you don't get drowsy is
is a is important too because they've
got some you know some medicine you
could take
um but it's gonna it's gonna for me it's
gonna
knock you out and uh you might not be in
a position where you can afford to go to
sleep for
three hours how it works is relief band
stimulates a nerve in the wrist that
travels to the part of the brain that
controls nausea
then it blocks the signal in your brain
that's that's your brain is sending to
your stomach
telling you that you're sick um relief
ban is
the only over-the-counter wearable
device that has been used in hospitals
and oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting
and if you know someone who deals with
nausea then i would recommend relief ben
my
um daughter also is uh she has inherited
this for me
uh she's very grateful to have inherited
my emotion sickness
uh aptitude and so i've given this to
her to her as well and it works great
this holiday season helps someone
reclaim their life from the fear of
nausea right now relief band has an
exclusive offer
just for matt walsh listeners if you go
to reliefband.com
and use promo code walsh you'll receive
20 off so head to
dot r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com and use our
promo code walsh for 20
off well ever since the media declared
joe biden the winner of the 2020
election
uh the left has wanted those of us on
the right to understand two things
first that they desperately wish to heal
our national wounds and
unite with us as one people and also
that we are vile sub-human barely
sentient
redneck scum now these two messages
would seem to be
in tension with each other but it may
only appear to me
it may only may only appear that way to
me because i myself am barely sent in
redneck scum i don't know credit where
it's due new york times op-ed writer
wajihat
ali has found a way to merge these two
apparently conflicting messages in a
piece for the times that provides i
think an extraordinarily clarifying look
into the elitist left-wing mentality ali
describes his attempts to
reach out to trump supporters and
explained
why he's now given up the effort i think
it may be useful um
before examining the article though to
review
one of ali's outreach efforts on cnn
earlier in the year
this is a segment with don lemon and
never trump guru rick wilson maybe you
saw this a few months ago
but ali performs his rather poor
impression of a blue-collar conservative
mocking them for not knowing how to
spell or read a map this again is the
guy who's trying to reach out to
conservative voters
but here he is on don lemon show watch
this he also knows deep in his heart
that donald trump couldn't find ukraine
on a map if you had the letter u and a
picture of an actual physical crane
next to it he knows that this is you
know
an administration defined by ignorance
of the world
and so that's partly him playing to
their base and playing to their audience
uh
you know the the the credulous boomer
rube demo that backs donald trump
um that wants to think that that that
donald trump's a smart one and they're
y'all elitists are dumb
you will you elitist with your geography
and your maps
and your spelling even though you're
reading
yeah you're reading you know your
geography
knowing other countries sipping your
latte
all those lines on the map
only they may let us know where ukraine
is
sorry i apologize yes some flaws in his
outreach strategy may already be obvious
i don't know
but the times piece sheds even more
light on it ali
begins this is what he says 73 million
americans voted for donald trump
he doubled down on all his worst vices
and he was rewarded for it with 10
million more votes than he received in
2016.
the majority of people of color rejected
his cruelty and vulgarity
but along with others who voted for joe
biden we are now being lectured by a
chorus of voices
including pete buttage and ian bremmer
to reach out to trump voters and
empathize with their pain this is the
same advice that was given after
trump's 2016 victory and for nearly four
years
i attempted to take it believe me it's
not worth it
then uh he explains that his islamic
faith
calls him to quote repel evil with good
and he said that you know because of
that he tried to find common ground with
trump supporters now on second thought
perhaps labeling them
evil that needs to be repelled may not
have been a good starting point for this
project i don't know
but here's how he went about it pay
attention to this
this is what he did so in late 2016 i
told my speaking agency to book me for
events in the states where trump won
i wanted to talk to the people the media
calls real americans from the heartland
which is of course america's synonym for
white people
trump's most fervent fan base uh over
the next four years i gave
more than a dozen talks to universities
companies and
a variety of faith-based communities my
standard speech was about how to build a
multicultural coalition of the willing
my message was that diverse communities
including white trump supporters
could work together to create a future
where all of our children
would have an equal shot at the american
dream okay so
for ali reaching out means delivering
lectures on multiculturalism
this is what empathizing looks like in
his world namely it looks like a bunch
of people
sitting in chairs listening obediently
while he explains things to them
and how did he know that his outreach
efforts failed well here he is
explaining that
he says those in the audience who
supported trump came up to me and
assured me they weren't racist
they often said they enjoyed the talk if
not my politics
still not one told me they'd wavered in
their support for him instead they
repeated conspiracy theories and fox
news talking points about crooked
hillary
all right so the audience listened
politely
with an open minds you know credit to
them
that that's that's better than i would
do if i was sitting listening to this
guy talk about multiculturalism i don't
think i would be sitting politely with
an open mind
uh nor would i enjoy the talk but ali
was shocked and appalled to discover
that at the end of his presentation they
still held their own opinions
rather than holding his opinions and if
this wasn't bad enough ali shares that
you know he spent a whole hour and a
half in a car with a trump supporter
and even after that after the dumb rube
had been exposed to ali's brilliance in
such close quarters for that long
he still wouldn't change his world view
if you can believe it he says
in ohio i spent 90 minutes on a drive to
the airport with a retired trump
supporter
we were cordial to each other we made
jokes and we shared stories about our
families
but neither of us changed our outlook
they'll never take my guns ever he told
me
explaining that his facebook feed was
filled with articles about how clinton
and democrats would kill the second
amendment and steal his guns
well yeah although he didn't like some
of trump's tone
and comments he didn't believe that
trump was racist in his heart
you heard that right a retired man
refused to alter his deepest convictions
based on a 90-minute conversation
with a new york times op-ed writer some
people are just
hopelessly stubborn i suppose ali then
concludes a note that is uh that is
as self-pitying as it is
self-aggrandizing he says
we cannot help people who refuse to help
themselves trump is an extension of
their id
their culture their values their greed
he is their defender and savior
he is their blunt instrument he is their
destructive drug of choice
don't waste your time reaching out to
drum voters like i did
just as in 2016 i don't need trump
supporters to be humiliated to feel
great again
i want them to have health insurance
decent paying jobs and security for
their family
i don't want them to suffer but i also
refuse to spend any more time trying to
understand and help
the architects of my oppression i will
move forward along
with the majority who want progress
equality and justice for all americans
if trump supporters decide they want the
same they could always reach out to me
they know where to find me ahead of them
now call me crazy but it seems unlikely
that a retiree from ohio could be the
architect of anyone's oppression
much less the oppression of a wealthy
metropolitan media pundit
but anything is possible in a mind
clouded
by its own sense of entitlement and you
know we should be grateful
for for this opportunity to gaze into
such a mind as disorienting as the
experience may be
because it tells us something important
about the unity which the left seeks
as ali makes clear again and again he is
only
interested in uniting with those who
will give up their dirty habit of
disagreeing with him
his idea of compromise is for the two
sides to come together
and agree that he is right about
everything
i think submission is a better word for
the relationship that he seeks
and the relationship that much of the
left seeks and we can hardly be blamed
for
declining the invitation
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so trump's team had a press conference
yesterday where they laid out their
voter fraud claims
uh a lot of discussion in the media
afterwards has been
about the the the physical uh
spectacle of of the of the press
conference rudy giuliani
was very sweaty apparently um he had uh
hair dye dripping down his face and so
that's been the big headline
that that was even the headline on on
the drugs report
but here's the thing you know that kind
of thing that's what you focus on the
fact that he was sweating and maybe he
was hot in the room
okay i can sweat too so i'm not going to
judge the guy for that
and you know he's wearing a suit that's
what this is one of the things as men
this is a this is a burden we care we
have to wear suits even matter what the
temperature is
that's the only formal attire we're
allowed to wear so uh
the fact that he's sweating or he had
hair dye that's what you focus on
if if you're an idiot or if you're too
afraid to talk about
the actual substance and in the media of
course i think it's sort of a bit of
both a lot of idiots
a lot of people that are afraid to talk
about the actual substance as for the
substance
um many different types of allegations
were made it was a i think a 90-minute
press conference rudy in particular
asked i thought a number of salient
questions
brought up a number of irregularities
we're calling them now that need to be
investigated
um and so that was sort of one one thing
um and a lot of that
i've been saying all along some of the
stuff that rudy was talking about
you know these these are these are the
things i think we should be focusing on
also early voting
mail and voting mass mail-in voting
late ballots coming in i think these are
the issues that
that no matter what happens with the
election need to get our focus
and this is something that again no
matter what happens 2024
um if republicans don't resist this if
we if
if this is what it's going to be now
forget about voter fraud for a minute
but if we're just going to have mass
mail-in voting early voting
you know where you can vote anytime for
six months up to the election
um it's it's going to be a total
disaster it's going to be what this has
been
every single damn election cycle
something for republicans to keep in
mind um
so there's that part of it okay now we
could talk about that
and those to me are the sort of sober uh
not quite as dramatic or exciting issues
but important and then there's sidney
powell
who alleges no less than the greatest
crime in american history
i mean this is an absolutely sensational
claim that she's making
doesn't make it wrong doesn't mean it
doesn't mean it's untrue
sometimes sensational extraordinary
things are true
oftentimes they're not sometimes they
are but we should just be clear about
what she's actually alleging her
if it's true this is one of the most
significant things that has ever
happened in the country
and it's also the utter destruction of
our way of life of our democracy our
republic
it's been totally destroyed what she
alleges is that um
there was a plan to rig the voting
machines
and to switch millions of votes from
trump to biden that's what she says
again this is this is separate from
issues of
poll watchers not being allowed in
ballots being counted late
all that kind of stuff this is an
entirely different thing and here's what
that's what she's saying
uh according to pal trump not only won
but one in a landslide i think she said
um
i don't want to miss quota but i think
she she has she has said or speculated
that he may have gotten like 80 million
votes
now i i would say before we even look at
this that
that doesn't seem plausible to me take
voter fraud
out of the equation you know
modern america i don't see donald trump
getting 80 million votes i don't see any
republican
ever getting 80 million votes i could be
wrong
but anyway so she thinks trump wanted a
landslide and that the votes were
switched
and um and the machine is key the
machine was rigged here she is talking
about it
i'm talking about some massive straight
lines up in the vote tallies
in the middle of the night after they've
supposedly stopped counting
and that's when the dominion operators
went in
and injected votes and changed the whole
system and it affects
votes around the country around the
world
and all kinds of massive interests
of globalist dictators corporations
you name it everybody's against us
except president trump
and we the people of the united states
of america we will not be intimidated
american patriots are fed up with the
corruption from the local level
to the highest level of our government
and we are going to take this country
back we are not going to be intimidated
we are not going to back down
we are going to clean this mess up now
president trump won by a landslide we
are going to prove it
and we are going to reclaim the united
states of america for the
people who vote for freedom so those are
the claims
um we haven't seen evidence of those
claims
we haven't she says she has the evidence
we haven't seen it
i mean you have not seen it if you're
watching this i haven't seen it
and speaking of which tucker tucker
carlson gave last night
uh i thought a truly great monologue
and i would recommend watching after
this show and after you watch all the
other daily wire shows then you can go
watch tucker carlson's model i thought
it was really
it was it was very good it was honest
and clarifying
uh i think probably the most important
monologue that anyone has delivered on
cable news since the election which
maybe is kind of a low bar but still
that's where i would put it
it was very very good and he said that
um
powell hasn't even hasn't hasn't he
contacted powell's people
asked to see some evidence of this so
that he could you know talk about it
and she refused to give the evidence but
also importantly in in
this is the part i think we should focus
on because a lot of the focus has been
on the claim
tucker made that powell won't show him
the evidence
more importantly tucker is saying that
powell hasn't even showed the trump camp
her evidence so here's uh tucker carlson
we took sydney powell seriously we no
intention of fighting with her we've
always respected her work
we simply wanted to see the details how
could you not want to see them
so we invited sidney powell on the show
we would have given her the whole hour
we would have given her the entire week
actually and listened quietly the whole
time
at rap detention that's a big story
but she never sent us any evidence
despite a lot of requests polite
requests not a page
when we kept pressing she got angry and
told us to stop contacting her
when we checked with others around the
trump campaign people in positions of
authority they told us
powell has never given them any evidence
either nor did she provide
any today at the press conference powell
did say that electronic voting is
dangerous and she's right we're with her
there
but she never demonstrated that a single
actual vote was moved illegitimately by
software
from one candidate to another not one
so why are we telling you this we're
telling you this
because it's true and in the end that's
all that matters
the truth it's our only hope
it's our best defense and it's how we're
different from them
we care what's true and we know you care
too
that's why we told you maybe cindy
powell will come forward soon with
details on exactly how
this happened and precisely who did it
maybe she will we are certainly hopeful
that she will what happened with the
vote counting this month
and at the polling places in detroit and
the polling places in philadelphia and
so much
else actually matters
it matters no matter who you voted for
it matters whether or not you think this
election is already over
until we know the answers to those
questions conclusively and we can agree
on them
this country will not be united okay now
what this would mean is that sydney
powell
is alleging she has evidence that she
alone
has evidence of the greatest crime in
american history and not one single soul
on earth has seen it but her
that is that's the situation we're
facing here now a few things a few
brief points i want to make first of all
tucker carlson whether you agree or
disagree with what he just said i don't
know how you could disagree with it
i mean all he's saying is we need
evidence for sensational claims
what what is there to disagree with
um but even if you whether you do or
don't
the fact is he's getting a hell of a
blow back from his audience because of
this
he knew that he would get bo back from
his audience
and i just want to be very clear about
something here because i'm seeing some
of the claims on social media and
twitter
that people say oh tucker sold out he's
sold out
he's a grifter no no tucker carlson is
not a sellout and he's not a grifter
this is not how selling out works this
is not how grifting works let me let me
tell you how selling out and grifting
works from the perspective of
a conservative in the media which of
which i am one
um a sellout and a grifter
in conservative media is someone who
will never say
anything that will upset their own
audience
that's someone who always tells his
audience everything the audience wants
to hear and already thinks
pandering is another word for it a
sellout a grifter is someone in
conservative media or you know or or any
media for their own audience
who will never upset their own audience
if somebody is going on in front of
their audience and saying
something that they know their audience
will not want to hear
and that may hurt their ratings and that
will bring in all the hate mail
say whatever you want doesn't mean you
have to agree with what they said but
you cannot accuse them of selling out
that is them being honest about what
they really think
and to punish them for it and say i'm
done with this person
you're done with them for being honest
with you
this you're gonna you're gonna punish
someone so so you want someone who's not
being honest
you're looking for someone to pander to
you and tell you exactly what you
already think
so that's the first thing you know there
there
there are a lot of conservatives in
media over the last four years who have
done
nothing but pander to their audience not
one damn thing except pander to their
audience
and a lot of them get the credit for
being the truthful ones
and the conservatives of media who will
actually be honest and upset their own
audience on occasion
they're the ones who get uh blasted for
being
dishonest and you know selling out and
all that it's exactly totally backwards
um so that's that's the first thing and
in terms of the claims i just go back to
you know we need to see the evidence
for it um there's no way you can accept
as gospel
as a claim this sensational without
seeing the evidence now you could say
well sidney powell has no
obligation to show us the evidence she
has to show it in court i absolutely
agree i've been saying this from the
very beginning
my take on this is bring your evidence
to court uh i'm i 100
agree with that and i have an open mind
and bring it to court
and let's let's hash it out um the only
problem is that
if you don't want to provide the
evidence to the court of public opinion
if you don't want to provide the
evidence to
the media and in fact if you're going to
um if you're going to react almost
offended that the media would even
expect for you to provide evidence
then why are you in front of the media
every damn day
talking about the evidence you won't
show them so that's a problem cindy
pal's on tv
every single freaking day talking about
the evidence she refuses to show anybody
uh so you know if you're if you're going
to do that
if you're going to go in front of
someone and say i've got this evidence
of course they're going to say can i see
it
you can't that's oh how rude sidney
powell later came out and responded to
tucker and said he was being rude and
aggressive and
okay well it's it's a perfectly
reasonable thing you tell someone you
have evidence of something they say can
i see it
um and then the second point is fine so
we gotta we gotta hash this out in court
fully on board with that
but there are a lot of people who are
repeating sidney powell's claims as
fact they haven't seen the evidence
there's no place for that
so um we'll see what happens and and and
here's
the final point if
sydney powell has uncovered the greatest
crime in american history
and is single-handedly going to save the
american republic
then she is one of the great heroes in
american history
um if however this is
a lie or scam then
she's one of the great villains in
american history it's kind of like one
or the
other it's it's one extreme or the other
right now that's what we're dealing with
there might be a little bit of room in
between but i think we're looking at one
extreme or the other
and we'll find out which one it is
number two the cdc has released its
guidelines for thanksgiving um here's
the
daily wire report once i pull it up
it says okay so if you're wondering what
the cdc thinks about
what you should be doing for
thanksgiving
so as a center for disease control
prevention on thursday urged americans
not to travel over thanksgiving instead
recommending that they gather virtually
to celebrate the traditional family
holiday the agency's coven 19 incident
manager dr
henry welk said the tragedy that could
happen is that one of your family
members
from coming together in this family
gathering actually could end up being
hospitalized and severely ill
uh or die so um
that's what's at stake you could kill
your grandmother we've been hearing a
lot about people killing grandmothers
um andrew cuomo has effectively actually
done it
by the hundreds so here's here are their
recommendations
bring your own food your own drinks
plates cups and utensils
wear a mask and safely store your mask
while eating and drinking
avoid going in and out of the areas
where food is being prepared or handled
such as in the kitchen um
use single-use options like salad
dressing and condiment packets
and disposable items like food
containers plates and utensils
and then it also says eat outdoors
limit the number of guests clean and
disinfect frequently
have guests bring their own food and
drink
all right so i mean it's i read this and
i think like it sounds to me
um that if i just sit down stairs
and watch football and let the women
cook you know that that honestly is the
safest thing that's me
looking out for their well-being so i
have to tell my wife that
i'd love to help and the other thing is
i'd love to help clean too
afterwards but i just really feel like i
need to segregate myself
and uh we can't have too many people
around and so i think i think that's
what that's what i'm gonna do
for for the for the sake of safety um
just
making sure that you know nobody gets
sick i am going to isolate myself
in the room with the tv and just watch
uh football
in fact i'll even tell my wife you can
bring me my meal down in the room and
i'll just eat it down there
um again just this is a sacrifice i'm
gonna make
because i love the family that much so
these are very serious recommendations
that we should take from uh
from the cdc all right number three
this is uh this is an interesting poll
because it's one of those polls
where whether you interpret the results
in a positive or negative way
negative way and it depends entirely on
the
uh assumptions and the biases that you
bring to it so like most polls i guess
but this poll got a lot of headlines and
the headline is 46 percent of voters
say trump should concede immediately
46 say he should concede immediately
okay
uh and then goes to the text of the
article says 46 of registered voters
said trump should concede right away
while another 32 percent said he should
concede if he is
unable to back up his claims of
widespread fraud
just 12 percent said president should
not concede no matter what
and 9 didn't know or had no opinion
you'd always rely on that 9 the i don't
know
what was there an election
by the way when it comes to this poll
there is an obvious correct answer here
the people in the 36 percent i think
what was the 36 or 34
the 36 camp they're correct that is the
correct answer
the correct answer is if he doesn't have
evidence to back up all his claims he
should resign or not resign rather
concede
um that's that is the objectively
correct answer
the idea that he should concede even
before the the court cases have been
hashed out and before he's had a chance
to present all
his evidence that's ridiculous and also
the idea that he
shouldn't concede no matter what even if
he can't present the evidence
evidence he still still shouldn't
concede that is also absurd i think that
those two
um stances on both
extreme ends of the spectrum are equally
as absurd
and uh finally
going to mental flaws
which is a apparently a publication the
issue of
mall santas this year and if you're a
parent maybe you've wondered about this
uh what's going to happen with mal
santos here's the report considering
that kova 19 spreads easily through
close contact it's no surprise that kids
won't be sitting on santa claus lap and
whispering their wish list right into
his ear this year
but while some seasonal santas are only
holding visits over zoom this year
you might overzoom oh my gosh so what
you wait in line at the mall
and there's a and you get up there and
there's a laptop to talk to
santa via zoom uh it says you might
still be able to say hello to your local
mall santa in person
uh jill renslow mall of america's senior
vice president of development says santa
is absolutely coming to the mall of
america this year
but it's going to be a different
experience based on kovan 19
requirements
instead of sitting out in the open the
santa clause at minnesota's mall of
america
will be posted up in a workshop so
people can snap family photos at a safe
distance
patriots patrons won't be able to decide
to visit on a whim
either to cut down on crowds and long
lines all sessions must be booked in
advance
through the shopping center's website so
what is this like a zoo
he's gonna be behind glass in his
natural environment
and you can just you can line up and
take pictures maybe tap on the glass
he'll come over
oh he's looking at us um i maybe it'll
be something similar
at the uh local bass pro shops here in
nashville which i have
i have sung its praisings praises
multiple times on this show
um they have a a santa
and so their their strategy is santa
is wearing a visor and he's behind glass
and so the kids can go up to the glass
and i was watching people do this
you wait in line and you go up to the
glass
and then you can just stand behind the
glass and wave at santa and he waves at
you
and then you could turn around and they
take a picture with you with him behind
the glass and you standing there
and in the picture it's gonna look like
santa's in prison
so it's a little weird you know i i i
would say
maybe if you're a parent and you know
you're trying to keep the santa thing
going
this year might not be a good year for i
think it raises a lot of questions
like he's santa claus he's magical he
isn't isn't there some magical force
field or whatever that he can use
do we really have to worry about santa
claus giving us covid
these are questions that your your kids
might have
um why can't santa claus come up with a
vaccine he's santa claus
you travel the entire world at the speed
of light
do anything these are all these are all
uh questions that an inquisitive mind
might uh might come up with so if your
child is inquisitive
maybe don't bring them to santa if a
child's stupid though then
then don't worry about it makes life
easier in a lot of ways we'll get to our
daily cancellation in just a second
but you know we all are fed up with the
legacy media the mainstream media we've
had enough of that especially with
with uh four years of trump and how they
performed
and how they've acquitted themselves not
very well to put it mildly
and uh during the election as well and
but here's the thing
if you're if you're fed up with the
legacy media then rather than
continuing to go to them for your news
and information how about replacing your
cable and your new subscriptions with
the daily wire we have big plans for the
next year
we're very excited about candice owens
is joining the daily wire we've got an
entertainment channel that's launching
we've got investigative journalism we're
going to be doing
uh we're teaming up with prageru by the
end of the year all of their videos will
be available
on our platform and we're going after
the legacy media and we're going to do
it by building a huge membership base of
supporters
just like you right now just to show you
we're serious we're offering 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe but pay attention to this
because it's the last day you can get
this deal so go right now
sign up members get our articles ad free
you get access to all of our live
broadcasts in the show library full
three hours of ben shapiro show
all access to become an all access
member you also get to take part in all
access discussions
readers pass content all of that and
more so remember that's 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe replace the legacy media with
the daily wire
you won't regret it all right let's get
to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we're
going to be canceling everybody involved
in this video from a publication called
the cut
which is i believe an offshoot or
property of new york magazine
the video is titled so what exactly are
white people superior
at and after setting up that straw man
it is
mostly an opportunity for a succession
of non-white people to air their
complaints against white people
complaints often based around degrading
stereotypes sometimes bizarre
stereotypes
stereotypes which lead me to suspect
that these individuals have never met
a white person in their entire lives um
i'm not just canceling the cut for this
by the way
and and uh and the bigots in the video
that we're gonna play in a moment of
course i am cancelling that but also
youtube for allowing it on their
platform and for permitting it to be
monetized
under normal circumstances i would have
no problem
with either of those things i would say
sure you know
this is ridiculous and and uh and
bigoted but
it's fine to have it on youtube um the
problem
is that youtube would never in a million
years allow this video in the reverse
to appear on their platform if it's a
free speech platform and they're
allowing whatever content fine
but this video in the reverse would not
be allowed on any platform
anywhere and certainly would not have
advertisers attached to it we all know
that so
all right let's uh let's get to it what
exactly are white people superior at
well according to television everything
a white man could fly
even a white woman she could be four
foot one she knew karate she could take
down 15 people
okay let's stop it there for a moment um
she says white people can fly in the
movies
yes those are superhero films you're
referring to
claiming that white people actually have
this ability in real life do you know
what a superhero film is
did you think that the avengers is a
documentary
just because a white person could do
something in a film it doesn't mean that
the filmmakers are claiming that all
white people
can do that thing when you watch
sherlock holmes nobody's trying to say
that all white people are brilliant
crime solvers in fact
most of the other people in the movie
are also white and they can't do
what sherlock holmes can do i shouldn't
have to explain
any of this but here we are and this
gives you an idea of the mentality that
we're encountering here uh the mentality
of a person who thinks that
a white superhero flying on film is some
sort of
white supremacist statement it only gets
worse from here so
buckle up what are white people superior
at now i'm not gonna make any rude
comments
um about what you just witnessed there
because that's not like me
you know that and i think your arguments
don't have as much weight
when you go for cheap shots i will only
say that
what you're witnessing here is the
torture killing of a straw man this is a
straw man being drawn and quartered this
would be a human rights violation if it
was happening to a real person but it
isn't and that's the point
they're pretending that there's some
prevalent view out there that white
people are superior
as it as if as if anyone's going around
making that argument
nobody's making that argument that's the
argument they want us to make
that's the case they wish they were
arguing against
but it isn't so instead they pretend it
is
and this is the result they they just
keep talking
mostly about their pets white people
love gay dogs like that's
all you see cats letting them get on
your countertops while you're cooking
yes i get that you love your pet but
like you need to take it everywhere
like everywhere i guess you know hey
emotional support animals i guess
i almost have some common ground here
because i also hate pets
but that's not a white thing emotional
support animals are not a white thing
that's a left-wing pampered entitled
urbanite thing
and that's the version of white person
that the people in this video are
attacking
i used to live in i just moved from
rural pennsylvania nobody in rural
pennsylvania has
emotional support animals i can tell you
that although my neighbor did have a
house pig
i'm not making that up they had an
actual pig that wouldn't that was
you know it would hang out in their
house some sometimes a pig would escape
and come onto our yard
um it wasn't an emotional support pig
though
i i have a feeling if i had asked them
oh is this your emotional support animal
i would have gotten shot
so um no this is this is a particular
type of white person that they're
attacking the irony here is that
they are also all entitled pampered
left-wing urbanites
have you seen one person in this video
who doesn't have almond milk in their
refrigerator
have you seen one person who'd be out of
place at a at a you know an
extinction rebellion climate change
protest no
these are non-white liberals attacking
white liberals
that's what's happening here what
exactly are white people superior
[Music]
men like making cereal casseroles what
kind of casserole
tuna it's always tuna what do you mean
it's always tuna
using mayonnaise in a lot of their
recipes
making bland food unseasoned chicken how
are you gonna start whole
spice wars and don't even use seasoning
on your food i mean come on
what exactly a white people superior
smelling funky
santa claus extreme water sports corn
mazes white people
are great at having fun that's a
function
of white supremacy because they just
don't have as many stresses
as we do white people are very superior
at their privilege in utilizing it we do
not have the privilege to do whatever
and however we want to
oh he doesn't have privilege sure yeah
he's oppressed he's a victim of white
supremacy in fact
he's so scared of murderous white
supremacists that he's appearing in a
video
published by a major media company where
the entire point is to make fun of white
people for being frivolous foul-smelling
idiots
who don't know how to properly season
their food which again on that
on that score that's a criticism of the
kale chopping vegans in their own social
circles
come down here to tennessee you'll find
plenty of wonderfully seasoned food
often cooked by white people white
people who we should know
smell just fine okay let's get back to
it
what exactly are white people superior
insecurity pretending
fear being fearful of nothing being
ignorant
yes insecurity and fear right you are
you are literally appearing in a video
where the whole point is to denigrate
another race to make yourself feel
better
but they're the insecure ones okay then
letting their egos control their every
move privilege truly killing victimizers
playing the victim congratulating
themselves over that
they're incompetent at or that should
have already been done they're superior
at being
and now they're talking about egos yes
egos again i have to remind you
about the video that you are currently
appearing in a whole lot of ego here
so what exactly are white people
superior honey lying stealing and
cheating manipulation
withholding information lying telling
lies what kind of laws
uh the lies of history they say that
history is written by the victor
but the victor could be replaced by the
colonizer
what are white people superior at
conquering imperialism
imperialism colonizing colonizing
colonialism colonization colonization
they might be better at that than us
and everybody else really they ballsy
they rose up all over the world
and they walk into everybody's house and
says oh this is nice i'm gonna take your
sh
and they have no qualms about it they
can take anything baby
okay so they really did find a list of
every person
who's bought kombucha in manhattan in
the last month
take out all the white ones and invite
the rest to participate in this video
they were looking for an extremely
narrow perspective and they found it
what they found specifically is naked
bigotry hate and racism
these words are tossed around a lot
these days bigotry hate racism
but often they're lobbed at the wrong
targets here's an actual example if
anyone's wondering what
actual racists sound like when you roll
out the red carpet and invite them to
spill the racist beans here it is this
is it
this is exactly what it looks like so
what's the point of a video like this
why would new york magazine put
something like this out there
you know they turned off the comments on
youtube for for a reason they knew how
it would be received
if they actually did think that there
were white supremacists
who needed to be debunked um
they knew that this video wasn't going
to achieve that it's not like this is
well-meaning but misguided like they
actually thought a nazi would watch this
and go wow you know what
i am terrible and i do smell bad and i
should expand my my casserole horizons a
bit
no this wasn't me this was meant
entirely to provoke
that was quite obviously its sole
intention that's it
but provoke what well provoke bigotry
hatred and racism
that after all is how you get bigotry
hatred and racism
they are self-replicating viruses
basically
if you want someone to be a racist just
be
racist towards them it may not work okay
you may not be able to provoke racism
out of everyone or even most people
especially in this country that way but
it's the best hope you have
so the idea here is to is to inflame
some of that white supremacist bigotry
which the likes of new york magazine
finds to be in such short supply
this has been the lefts and the media's
tactic for a long time now if there
isn't enough racism to suit your
political needs
you can first of all fake it you know
just take the jesse smellette approach
the hoax or you can be a bigot yourself
hoping to get some bigotry in return
this is called race hustling
race baiting and it's far more insidious
than those terms make it sound it's it's
really quite evil
actually and so everybody involved
in this video is canceled permanently
forever and always
may god have mercy on their souls
because they'll need it
and we're going to leave it there for
this week have a great weekend everybody
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there